and she's gone ahead and married this
beautiful brother
some sisters in today's time living at
today's time would be like
if i look like sana khan you know if i
had her i don't know whatever
features and looked like her and had the
money and the fame
marrying someone of religious someone
that looks like a sheikh
you know i'm definitely i definitely
won't be doing that
why did sister sana khan decide to take
this move
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
salaam alaikum is two brothers and
sisters and dear friends sister
khan i don't know much about her but
what i do know is
that she has recently started to take us
dean seriously
and she's gone ahead and married this
beautiful brother
now a lot of sisters maybe not a lot of
sisters
maybe some sisters in today's time
living at today's time would be like
if i look like sana khan you know if i
had her i don't know whatever
features and looked like her and had the
money and the fame
marrying someone of religious someone
that looks like a sheikh
you know i'm definitely i definitely
won't be doing that
why did sister sana khan decide to take
this move
let's talk about that that is so
important brothers and sisters because
the prophet salallahu told us
that when a woman is seeking marriage in
a husband she should look for two things
number one
and number two good adam good character
because in today's time a lot of people
they go for the
taco in the context of dean and how do
they how do they measure that
oh he wears a thob and he says and he
talks a lot of islamic
terminologies and it looks the part with
the fob etc and then you marry this guy
and he's a vile disgusting individual in
the context of
his ada his character the way he carries
himself is disgusting
he's somebody who has a disease in the
heart where he
he thinks everybody's guided by himself
and this is why it's so important the
prophet peace be upon him
character you know not a lot of people
who have
talked when they even kind of said this
that person you have taco in that
context
why did sister sama khan go and marry a
brother
who a lot of sisters if they were in
their position
may have said um i would i wouldn't go
that i would want to go for someone more
you know tall
dark and handsome and once again i want
to make something i'm not saying the
brother marshall is a beautiful handsome
brother
and beauty and handsomeness is
subjective
but what i'm trying to say is like in
today's time brother and sisters
this is what a lot of people go for but
sister sana khan
talk something serious and i'm sure
she's not gonna marry someone she's not
attracted to
but that's good but she specifically
went for someone of knowledge
now i don't know this brother's
knowledge how knowledgeable he's excited
practicing is
we judge from us apparently we don't
know much about him um
so and we don't know but what i'm trying
to say is the fact that she made that
a priority is something that we need to
admire and our sisters who are watching
this
and our brothers as well sometimes when
we go and look for someone
and we're like okay yeah i think they're
attractive i'm attracted to them
um you know but you're just uh kind of
put off of their village religiosity you
know
and you tend to go for somebody who's
more good looking now guys i'm going to
mention something i don't need you guys
to get mad at me the marriage
documentary
yes how does it relate to this guys i
swear upon allah i'm not holding it back
we've got the production ready but we
are waiting on the development of our
app to help young people
help muslims in general to get married
so please forgive me but reason i'm
coming to this is because i learned my
lesson
in a very bad way which you will see in
the documentary where i was getting to
know a sister for marriage who i was
attracted to but things turned out so
nasty
so nasty i got and you will see that in
the documentary i can't go into detail
and that taught me a massive lesson
allah taught me such a lesson
where i put attraction over anything and
i'm not saying
that sister wasn't practicing per se the
element of practicing was there
but the beauty aspect of it was there
and a sister who may have
had not have same beauty but the um the
may not see beauty might have more deen
i
i preferred somebody who had a bit more
beauty and
maybe the dean is just mediocre and i
learned a massive lesson from that a
lesson where
your your jaws will drop to what
happened to me and my family
your your jaws will drop okay uh and
anyway that's all different story here
so now
brothers and sisters and and that's just
i was getting to know for marriage yes
subhanallah
but the issue is this may allah rectify
affairs and mine that when they come to
these aspects the prophet peace be upon
we are told
to look for taqwa this does not mean you
go and marry someone
that you're not attracted at all because
that's another disaster that you should
avoid
uh and i discuss in the magi documentary
as well you have to be attracted to your
partner
this is fundamental it's very important
for you to be attracted to
your partner but to go out and seek
someone that is like
super handsome etc i'll be honest with
you a lot of people who might be really
attractive sisters who have really
beautiful brothers who are really
handsome
they come with a lot of baggage i'm not
saying old they come with a lot of
baggage
so the fact that sister sana khan chose
somebody of knowledge yeah somebody who
fears allah you can see it in his
appearance and
it's in attack we do not know yet but
for someone at the statue of
fame um and somebody's wife i don't
like you know like a lot of brothers may
wanted to marry her
maybe because for her looks and
everything that she has
she has gone for somebody where a lot of
sisters would
never go for would never go for and i've
seen this as well
for example and a lot of brothers you
know when i was getting to
know people for marriage in in when i
was getting people marriage
a lot of times people would tell others
like there will be
issues where i'm getting to know sister
for marriage things are going well et
cetera and someone said oh you know he's
really strict
or he'll never let you come out of the
house he's one of those you know those
really strict tower guys and
so panel and then you think these are
all assumptions by the way yeah okay
they have no idea
these are just all assumptions so a lot
of people would
be like oh no don't marry him you know
he's too religious or this that etc and
this happens vice versa as well you know
oh that sister's too religious etc and
subhanallah we see
religion as somebody who may fear allah
subhanahu ta'ala
and who what what they're gonna do
remind you to pray and get close to
allah
hello mom yes come yes come come
come here
to have a partner who's going to remind
you he's going to wake you up for fajr
be it vice versa you know you can be
sister son khan
waking her husband up except for vice
versa i'm not saying one is more
pleasure than another
but the point is this brother and
sisters for to have someone to invest in
your hereafter
in a way where subhanallah to have a
right spouse will allow you to have a
righteous spouse
it's more important it's more beloved
because you're coming home
to peace you're coming home to love
you're coming home to somebody who cares
about you so much
that not only in this life they care
about you you know be careful when
you're crossing the road
watch out in your security or wherever
it may be but a partner that cares so
much for you
that he wants you protected in the
hereafter from the fire
so much so they remind you of salah they
remind you of making sure you play zakah
go in hajj and umrah together rather
than having a partner who just wants to
yeah let's get the latest and there's
nothing wrong with this but to make your
focus just to dunya
subhanallah it's going to come out the
cost of you losing the dunya
marry people who are practicing who are
god fearing inshallah
and yes you can be attracted to them
that's absolutely normal yeah so
basically guys
inshallah if we can give importance like
sisana khan to somebody's dean
and somebody reminding you of allah
rather than the looks
while i will be in a better place more
than sisters in our marriages
some people will learn the hard way like
i did when i was seeking marriage so i'm
telling you guys
guys look for somebody who is
religiously
they they do the important father things
mom and sisters inshallah
my daughters are staring okay thank you
um and um yeah inshallah instead of just
looking for someone's out appearance
because once that makeup comes off or
brother whatever comes off at the bottom
these days put makeup on as well um the
reality kicks and brothers and sisters
and you're going to live with the person
not the person till next time assalamu
alaykum